George Washington's exploits as both a
politician and general are well known
but should he be equally recognized as a
businessman
according to author Edward L'Engle the
answer is an unqualified yes in his new
book first entrepreneur how George
Washington built his and the nation's
prosperity L'Engle makes the case that
washington's business acumen and
economic outlook are just as important
to understanding the man and the country
he helped form he was a big believer in
individuals creating their own wealth
and by virtue of their own hard work he
took those principles and he applied
them to the country as a whole as
president because he believed that Mount
Vernon and what he did at Mount Vernon
was a microcosm of what other
entrepreneurs could do for America let's
get a sense then of what he did at my
burnin what did he make what did he sell
well he started out with tobacco that
was what he had inherited from his
ancestors that's what he knew tobacco
had a lot of different problems the
biggest problem was that and growing
tobacco in the colonial era he was
forced to work within the British credit
system that foster debt and I can tell
you that the one thing that Washington
feared most of all was debt so he
switched over to wheat and wheat
accomplished a lot of things it allowed
him to buy and to sell on his own
account to be his own entrepreneur to be
his own merchant and it also allowed him
because wheat was much less
labor-intensive to make his estate
self-sufficient and it became a huge
sprawling industry in its own right they
spun and they wove to create their own
clothing they cobbled their own shoes
they created their own iron work and
tools and of course I had a very
successful fishery as well those were
just in the early days later on he did
much more yeah including the distillery
including the distillery which we don't
want to forget that no never that was in
the last a couple years of his life and
it's interesting he had never had any
experience with that before but his farm
manager is a Scot named Jameis Anderson
suggested that he try it he studied it
carefully and then he took a chance it
was very profitable
Washington was a slave owner but
probably a good deal of work on his farm
was done by people who were forced to
work there does that undercut Washington
as a model entrepreneur well Washington
was great in many many ways and the
truly great individuals transcend their
times in many ways he did transcend his
times slavery was one area where it took
him some time to begin to understand the
fundamental problems and the fundamental
principles at issue
he didn't automatically react to it
either as a great good or as a great
evil but he studied it and what he
latched on to initially was not a kind
of a moral solely moral issue but was
based on the fundamental principle of
the right to work freely and the right
to enjoy the fruits of your labor freely
and the right to invest and prosper
freely and Washington believed that
industry and morality were two sides of
the same coin a moral man will be
industrious the industrious man is
therefore a moral man if you prevent a
man from being industrious on his own
account you corrupt him morally and you
corrupt yourself morally and it corrupts
the nation it innervates the nation he
began to see what this would do over the
long term to his own estate not just
looking in the short term free labor but
looking what would happen in the long
term enslaved people will do the minimum
possible naturally they don't want to be
enslaved they want to be free so they're
going to do the very minimum that you
tell them to do there
going to innovate they're not going to
experiment they're not going to work
hard because they want to they're only
going to do what they're told and how
are you going to grow over the long term
that way that was where he really saw
the evil in slavery
now what held him back from freeing
slaves earlier I think was because he
was a law-and-order guy who feared
social disruption and dislocation and he
was simply afraid of what would happen
but you have to give him credit that he
did eventually by the terms of his will
say that his slaves would be freed upon
Martha's death and of course Martha
didn't like that so she freed them
herself
earlier you titled chapter 3 of your
book which deals with the American
Revolution the road to economic freedom
is that how Washington and the nation
saw the fight for independence yes it
absolutely was he thought that economic
freedom was the basic goal to free
Americans from a system that prevented
them from taking off Americans in
Washington in particular believed in the
early 1770s that soon we would be able
to produce for ourselves agriculturally
we'd be able to develop manufacturing
industry and the only thing that really
prevented us from achieving that were
British restrictions on on American
entrepreneurship and so he believed that
that that was the the fundamental goal
he believed that initially that the war
against Britain should be an economic a
trade war now certainly he eventually
came to realize that this had to be a
military conflict but he initially hoped
that it would be an economic conflict
and trade war through boycott through
boycott why write this book in a
Washington live 200 years ago very
different America a very different world
what why is it relevant well part of it
is because it gives us a whole new
window
on to Washington and what made him tick
and to realize that he thought about
money he thought about the economy a lot
not because as we might think in the
21st century oh he was a greedy guy but
because he understood that that money
was the lifeblood of human society and
out that it was just extremely important
the principles that Washington believed
in in terms of personal entrepreneurship
in terms of National Economic Policy
work in industry are absolutely relevant
today and I think that by writing this
book I'm trying to set those before
Americans to to realize that these are
basic principles that that really we
need to return to as much as we can when
people think about founding fathers and
scientific experimentation they usually
think of Jefferson Franklin do you
believe Washington should also be put in
that camp yes but he should be put in
that camp in terms of being a hands-on
learner he was an experiential learner
if he wanted to be there in that tool
shed tinkering and learning how to
invent and experiment himself so for
example if he would receive ideas from
overseas about some new plow or some new
threshing device or some new grist mill
he wanted to be there and put it
together and learn how it worked himself
he was he had the mind of an engineer he
did believe in ideas but but he was the
type of guy he wanted to be in the
laboratory any new technology you should
study it experiment with it and then
apply it he also believed that it was
essentially the role of the rich to
underwrite these scientific
experimentations and innovated to
experiment and not the role of the
government to push for specific
industries or certain pathway it was
certainly not the role of the government
any form of subsidies government
subsidies he rejected out of
and Jefferson agreed with him on that he
wouldn't even consider it he did the
think it was only the role of the rich
certainly the rich should should invest
the money they should help set the
example perform the large-scale
experiments and that they should invest
the bulk of the capital needed to
develop new industries and new
technologies but he didn't think the
burden should be on them alone he really
believed that the burden was a shared
burden that was one of the reasons he
believed in education if individual
Americans would become well-educated
practically educated he believed in
practical education then they would be
able to read such things as Arthur
Young's annals of Agriculture which was
just absolute wealth of knowledge in
that publication about agriculture
experimentation and industry they could
share that they could learn from it they
could share it and they could enrich
each other he really believed that if
you created a situation in which
Commerce could thrive that people would
see their collective interest in staying
at peace and in working with each other
peacefully he thought that on the
frontier for example that if Americans
if white Americans and Native Americans
could trade with each other and they
could enrich each other through that
trade and through that Commerce that
naturally they would want to remain at
peace he saw that he thought the same
thing internationally as well that the
best guarantor to preventing war between
nations was to increase Commerce now he
did talk about how he wished war could
be banished from the face of the earth
but I don't think it was a utopian
vision it wasn't something that was
based on dreams it was something that
was based on hard solid facts